on est aujourd'hui au golf 2 à 50 ans en
Yvelines pour parler d'un rendez-vous
qui aura lieu le 14 octobre prochain le
Tea break gourmand à mes côtés Véronique
Chaplin l'organisatrice de l'événement
Arnaud courtier qui est le monsieur JO à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et Cady
Baradji Miss fitness France combien une
deux trois fois je crois trois fois
c'est ça alors Véronique qu'est-ce que
c'est cet événement
et bien dans la continuité du petit
break qui existe depuis 30 ans qui est
un rassemblement de sportifs de haut
niveau de toutes les disciplines pour la
bonne cause
nous avons décidé parce que
l'association est née dans les Yvelines
perdure de faire un événement pérenne au
cœur des Yvelines à Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines ça s'appelle le tibrac gourmand
parce que dans l'axe des enfants il y a
la prévention santé prévention santé
veut dire bonne alimentation donc le
côté gourmand c'est la présence de chef
du côté des personnalités et des
partenaires qui nous soutiennent donc un
événement avec 120 jeunes des collèges
de 50 ans en Yvelines deux trappes et de
Guyancourt et 120 adultes des
personnalités du sport du spectacle et
des chefs alors quand on vous invitait
Arnaud courtier c'est forcément pour
parler des Jeux Olympiques quel est le
rapport entre le tibrac et vous
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines au niveau des
Jeux Olympiques alors le rapport il est
simple il est évident on est on l'a dit
Véronique de le dire à 50 ans en
Yvelines au cœur des Yvelines
département olympique 50 ans en Yvelines
communauté de communes qui accueille les
Jeux Olympiques avec quatre sites et ce
que fait véronique est merveilleux parce
que ça va permettre d'aider et
d'accompagner des enfants dans un chemin
qui va vers les Jeux Olympiques grâce à
des programmes liés au sport liés à la
nutrition donc on est complètement dans
notre rôle aujourd'hui on vient d'ouvrir
récemment à Magny-les-Hameaux une école
avec le chef Thierry Marx donc voilà
c'est c'est le thème l'avenir et
exactement et les Jeux Olympiques c'est
fabuleux en soi mais en plus c'est
fabuleux parce que ça va nous permettre
de sensibiliser toute une population au
sport santé au sport bien-être à la
bonne nutrition dans ce cadre là donc il
est naturel pour nous pour 50 ans en
Yvelines d'être présent pour cet
événement et il y a aussi ce rapport
aussi avec le golfe forcément on sait
que 50 ans en Yvelines va accueillir les
épreuves de golf aux JO de 2024
forcément il y a un lien le golf ici le
golf en 2024 encore évident il y a deux
sports olympique phares sur notre
territoire le cyclisme et le golf Le
Golf on a accueilli en 2018 la Ryder Cup
on va accueillir les Jeux olympiques le
golf national sera le seul parcours du
monde à avoir accueilli ces deux
épreuves internationales c'est quand
même exceptionnel et puis le golf c'est
un sport pour tous aussi c'est un Super
Sport quel que soit l'âge on peut le
pratiquer toute sa vie donc c'est
fabuleux de le faire découvrir aux
enfants et il y aura également des
sportifs de haut niveau dont vous Kany
Baradji 3 fois Miss fitness France alors
qu'a dit qu'est-ce que vous allez faire
ce jour-là sur le petit break gourmand
alors moi déjà je remercie Véronique de
m'inviter sur cet événement je suis je
suis ravi de faire partie de cette
deuxième édition et pour ma part cette
année c'est encore plus particulier dans
étant donné que j'aurais la double
casquette de sportif de haut niveau et
d'enseignante du coup je suis professeur
de PS au lycée à Guyancourt s'appelle
CFA trajectoire et du coup jamais cette
année mes élèves avec moi de pour qu'ils
puissent aussi découvrir tout cet
environnement rencontrer des sportifs de
haut niveau et sortir justement de de
juste le cadre sportif scolaire ce qu'on
leur enseigne et voir un peu plus loin
ce que se peut leur apporter le sport
les sensibiliser au sport santé et
justement ce fil rouge qu'on a tous les
jeux olympiques 2024 est-ce que vous
allez jouer au golf ce jour-là alors non
je ne vais pas jouer ce jour-là parce
que je serai en cours le matin et que et
que je serai sur les ateliers je vais
encadrer un atelier en tant que sportive
et du coup je suis ravie de pouvoir être
là et surtout avec mes élèves on va
parler justement de ces ateliers
Véronique qu'est-ce que c'est ces
ateliers concrètement on leur apprend à
différents sports à gérer leurs émotions
peut-être qu'est-ce qu'on leur apprend
exactement alors il y a 10 sports
différents dont des sports olympiques
encadré chaque sport encadré par deux
sportifs de haut niveau de la discipline
donc ça passe du rugby au foot au judo
au golf à la boxe et à d'autres l'idée
c'est à travers ces olympiades et ces
ateliers c'est les valeurs la discipline
le bien vivre ensemble le sens du
collectif seul on va vite à plusieurs on
va beaucoup plus loin
s'amuser et surtout représenter ces
milliers d'enfants qui sont dans le
monde avoir cette chance de passer une
journée avec ces champions
iconiques qui viennent et je tiens à le
souligner totalement bénévolement que ça
soit les chefs les sportifs de haut
niveau si on perdure depuis 30 ans et
qu'on va vers 2024 avec ses enfants vont
toucher du doigt ce rêve c'est toute une
chaîne de solidarité derrière moi chacun
apporte sa pierre à l'édifice et ça
c'est extraordinaire donc pendant que
les personnalités jouent au golf en
parallèle les champions en cas de ces
120 jeunes et tout le monde va se
retrouver autour du concours chef
gourmand voilà alors vous faites le type
break depuis de nombreuses années depuis
30 ans si je me trompe pas depuis 30 ans
sinon celle qui fonctionne si je
comprends bien si ça a duré 30-30 ans
tout le monde me demande mais comment tu
fais tous les ans en plus une nouvelle
aventure j'ai un bon panel de sportifs
solides avec qui je travaille tout le
reste de l'année j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir dans ma carrière j'ai travaillé
chez Nike et orange avec des belles
personnes qui m'ont appris aussi
toute la partie marketing parce que il
faut être lucide quand on fait du
caritatif il faut être très
professionnel et derrière le caritatif
il y a des entreprises il y a des
agglomérations il y a les gens comme
Arnaud qui nous soutiennent
financièrement voilà il y a des dons
c'est précieux et puis il y a des
fameuses enchères caritatives juste
après Arnaud un petit mot peut-être par
rapport à ce que Véronique vient de vous
dire vous soutenez du coup
financièrement l'opération parce que
c'est important pour pour 50 ans en
Yvelines oui c'est important ça fait
partie de notre rôle tout simplement la
communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines s'occupe du
sport sur le territoire avec les villes
bien sûr nous soutenons des clubs des
associations dans tous les sports et là
on l'a dit on le répète on est sur
quelque chose de particulier quelque
chose pour les plus jeunes on est sur
notre territoire on est dans le sport
dans le sport vers l'olympisme et ce que
tu as évoqué les valeurs du sport c'est
essentiel et ça doit être
une grande partie de l'héritage de ses
futurs jeux olympiques c'est montrer aux
enfants à tout le monde mais aux enfants
c'est important que le sport c'est
important pour la santé physique et
intellectuel que le sport c'est le
premier vecteur de lien social donc
finalement faire du sport c'est le bien
vivre ensemble c'est le seu respecter
soi-même et c'est comment apprendre à
travailler avec les autres à recommencer
quand on rate parce que quand on fait du
sport on sait que en compétition on perd
plus souvent qu'on gagne et ça c'est un
message au futur entrepreneurs quelque
part vous réussirez pas toujours c'est
pas grave on se relève on y retourne
donc accompagner cette démarche à porter
ses valeurs pour nous c'est très
important oui on pense à l'après
finalement aux Jeux Olympiques on reste
pas sur un événement en 2024 on pense à
l'après on pense à l'après absolument
c'est la priorité en fait Véronique les
sportifs de haut niveau qui seront
présents est-ce que vous avez des noms à
nous annoncer ou la liste est pas encore
définitive alors c'est ce que je dis la
liste n'est jamais définitive si on
regarde la liste depuis 30 ans tous les
ans c'est magique parce que on a des
stars alors il y a des noms qui sont
très connus des rugbyman internationaux
des footballeurs qui sont présents comme
Olivier Dacourt les anciens du PSG
Philippe Candeloro parmi les fidèles
mais ce que j'ai envie de dire c'est que
il va y avoir 40 sportifs de haut niveau
qui sont tous titrés soit médaillés
olympiques soit champion du monde
champion d'Europe donc même si je vous
cite greg c'est génial qui fait du
squeletton derrière ce sport moins connu
il y a un homme exceptionnel qui a des
valeurs pas possible qui œuvrent pour
Paris 2024 et c'est ça le tibrac c'est
une quarantaine de champions tous
extraordinaire et et qui ont également
aux côtés de la prévention santé du
sport le côté éducatif parce qu'il y a
ceux qui vont travailler dans le sport
mais il y a ceux qui vont apprendre un
métier on va il y a un atelier où ils
vont apprendre la construction le
terrassement d'un terrain de golf ça
peut un moment donné aussi des velléités
à côté du
sportalités qui seront présentes ce
jour-là vous qu'est-ce que vous allez
leur apprendre à ces jeunes vous êtes
Miss fitness France est-ce que vous
allez leur faire faire des pompes des
tractions
des pompes avec calibrage
alors mes élèves en cours ils font déjà
beaucoup de pompes mais en l'occurrence
là je vais être sur ma première
casquette avant d'être championne de
fitness j'étais championne d'athlétisme
et donc moi je serai sur l'atelier
athlétisme sur ce sur le petit break
gourmand transpire un peu oui toujours
il le faut
Véronique a un petit mot sur les chefs
du coup qui seront présents ce jour-là
sur ce type break gourmand des chefs de
renommés quasiment international on peut
le dire des chefs de renommée
internationale et qui ont alors les
chefs c'est à la mode et ils ont plus de
chacun plus de 2 millions de followers
ce sont des Yvelines moi il y a donc
Erwan qui était pas 25 ans en Yvelines
il y a Xavier Pincemin qui est à
Versailles vainqueur de Top Chef il y a
Jean-Christophe broudy qui représente la
présidence de la République qui aura sa
belle toque voilà et qui se feront
partie du jury sur le concours chef ou
chacun va s'essayer pendant 30 minutes
mais dans la convivialité puisque il y
aura autant de points sur le côté santé
esthétique que le goût donc chacun a la
chance de gagner ce concours chef
avec plaisir toute façon ils vont faire
les apéros food qui vont accompagner le
dîner c'est à dire que rien n'est gâché
tout ce qui va être fait va être mangé
le soir pour reprendre des forces après
notre journée sportive forcément ils
sont ravis de participer à l'opération
ils sont ravis parce que en fait
sincèrement tout ça c'est dans la joie
la bonne humeur la convivialité et ce
que me disent tout le monde au tibrac
tout le monde enlève sa casquette du
quotidien pour redevenir un grand enfant
que ça soit un champion
PDG un enfant un bénévole tout le monde
est à égalité et c'était l'idée même
l'essence même du tibrac à la base mais
tout le monde sur terrain neutre pour la
bonne cause celle des enfants celle de
Paris 2024 celle de d'une belle France
qui doit retrouver voilà qui doit avoir
toutes ces valeurs mises en avant à
travers tous ces gens multiculturels les
enchères aussi le soir il y aura
également de très Bolos incroyables
il faut savoir que SOS Gazel
nous fonctionnons avec
moins de 10% de frais de fonctionnement
notre objectif c'est que tout l'argent
est pour les enfants ça reste une petite
association même si on a des grands
champions on a beaucoup de projets et
toute l'année on va là en quête au lot
et alors cette année on a des lots
exceptionnelles puisque c'est très varié
on a le maillot de Monsieur Messi du PSG
donc oui ça je pense qu'il est très
attendu mais nous avons également un
très beau scooter électrique offert par
les cycles Jacquot qui est à Versailles
nous avons un vélo électrique offert par
Intersport de mon repas en clair ce sont
les sportifs de haut niveau des Yvelines
et les entreprises des Yvelines qui
offrent les lots pour les enchères donc
ça c'est extraordinaire il y aura une
trentaine de lots et sur les 30 lots il
y aura d'îlots prestigieux j'ai un
chiffre en tête à atteindre parce qu'on
a beaucoup de choses à faire d'ici la
fin de l'année donc je compte sur le
public tout le monde est bienvenu pour
venir enchérir et je n'ai pas honte de
dire que lorsqu'on fait un don c'est
défiscalisable et vous récupérez 66% du
montant au niveau des impôts il faut le
dire parce que c'est un des avantages
fiscal en France et c'est une belle
action qui permet de se faire plaisir
tout en se faisant un joli cadeau utile
pour le pour Noël et les fêtes de fin
d'année ça fait rêver ses enchères
dernière question qu'est-ce qu'on peut
vous souhaiter Véronique pour le jour J
alors déjà la première ça fait 30 ans
qu'on a les dieux du ciel avec nous on a
toujours du soleil ou pour le mois un
temps qui permet de tout faire à
l'extérieur on va avoir à peu près 250
personnes dans la journée donc un beau
temps de la joie de la bonne humeur et
que tous les gens présents oublient un
peu leur tracas du quotidien pour passer
une belle journée conviviale qui est de
plein de belles énergies et que ses
enfants sont nourrissent que ça soit des
exemples pour la suite que ça les marque
à vie tout ce petit on a des exemples de
d'une personne qui est en une minute à
transformer avec une phrase un sourire
c'est ça notre souhait et qu'elle soit
gazelle perdure très longtemps que nos
enfants nos petits-enfants fassent durer
ces actions solidaires parce que je
crois qu'il y a rien qui rend plus
heureux que de faire plaisir aux autres
finalement donner sa rapporte beaucoup
et c'est vraiment le cas des gens de
Saga Mercedes de 26 de la Fondation
Française des jeux d'Arnaud et tous ces
bénévoles qui viennent apporter leur
pierre l'édifice voilà on vous le
souhaite en tout cas Véronique Chaplin
le petit break gourmand ce sera le 14
octobre prochain ici sur le golf de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines dans l'île de
loisirs